is the security compact with Kiev and
we're working with the
EU Ukraine parliamentary Association
in on our mission to Kev in December we
spoke to our Ukrainian counterparts uh
um we spoke about what the EU could do
to enhance support and security for
Ukraine both in the short and the long
term
we
debated your proposal about what we call
the key of security compact when we came
back we need to continue this discussion
and on behalf of this committee I'm very
pleased to be able to welcome the
co-authors of this document document
um Andrew yermack head of the office of
the president's Ukraine thank you for
being available given that the contacts
he'll be speaking from Kiev we also have
Anders for Robinson the former Secretary
General of NATO who will be with us in a
few moments so ladies and gentlemen a
warm welcome to all of you
uh we condemn relentlessly the war of
aggression against Ukraine and we will
ensure that the EU continues its
commitment and support uh to Ukraine's
if uh Financial humanitarian and
military equipment for Ukraine we will
support you for as long as it's
necessary
it's this European Parliament has called
Russia a state sponsor of terrorism it's
this house which is called
for the supply of heavy weapons and
tanks to Ukraine against this house
which has just voted for an amendment
which calls Our member states to support
the principles of the key of security
compact as a provisional immediate
solution for security in Ukraine
we've welcomed the decision of the
council last week to open up a seventh
tranche of 500 million euros their
support for Ukraine and 45 million
additional for training for Ukrainian
forces via the human mission
we need to add in all the bilateral
support to this directly from member
states we want to see Ukrainian Victory
we want to see Ukraine have its uh in
territorial Integrity as soon as
possible the question of immediate
guarantees for security for Ukraine
at the
may seem premature given the nature of
combat which is currently ongoing
however it is absolutely vital to look
at this we need to ask ourselves our
question about the post uh conflict
period how do we ensure security of
Ukraine and the entire continent the
consequences of the war in Ukraine are
major and can be seen in with the
specific request of Finland and Sweden
to join the NATO
Ukraine is
not part of NATO currently so it does
not benefit from Article 5 Clause the
aim is to give the concur Ukraine solid
security guarantees we need to keep in
mind the failure of the Budapest
memorandum we need to ensure that
Ukraine is never again invaded
um president zielinski
received a draft of the key of security
compact Mr umak and Mr Robinson you
co-ordered this report president
selinski asked you to work on a document
who is setting out the key points for
the post-war security architecture and
the Euro Atlantic area and ensuring
guarantees for Ukraine this nine-page
document calls on Western countries to
provide a political Financial military
and diplomatic resources to strengthen
kiev's ability to defend itself it
contains a range of recommendations
which call for a multi-level approach
for guarantees the first group says that
allies should try and strengthen the
Ukrainian Army so the country can defend
itself there needs to be in providing a
deterrent but also be able to defend its
Sovereign sovereignty when attacked
I'd like to give the floor to uh uh
guests so they can describe the pack
compact in detail we'd like to know what
support and what specific Investments
are you expecting from the EU
particularly in relation to Modern and
effective weapon systems arms transfer
as well uh intelligence support for
training or protection of Ukrainian
airspace Regional agreements
specifically in the Black Sea are
there's something that is envisaged
could you tell us what reaction there
has been to your document since it's
been published and what
evolution might take place I'd like to
now go the floor to Irma's payet the
vice president of the uh vice president
of the affect committee oh mercy of the
floor thank you very much Natalie dear
colleagues dear guests let me also thank
our guest speakers on behalf of the
committee on Foreign Affairs
it has been almost a year since the
beginning of unjustified Russian war of
aggression
and during this year Ukraine has been
fighting not only for its sovereignty
and territorial Integrity but also for
its right to exist as a free nation and
to choose a euro-atlantic path for its
future development and security
if you want to honor Ukraine's Brave
choice we need to start talking already
now about the security guarantees
Ukraine must obtain as soon as it will
manage to win this war and re-establish
peace on its territory
this is crucial in order to mobilize all
necessary political Financial military
and diplomatic resources to guarantee
that the horrible crimes we are
witnessing every day will never happen
again in the future
with that uh
in mind I strongly welcome the key of
security compact which includes clearly
identified security guarantees and the
joint strategic partnership to be
endorsed by current or Allied States and
Ukraine
as I had the opportunity to learn in
Kiev in December the goal of this
initiative is to enable Ukraine's
self-defense to deter an armed attack or
act of aggression and in case an attack
occurs to ensure that the sovereignty
territorial integrity and security of
Ukraine under the U.N Charter article 51
are guaranteed
needless to say as a future EU member
Ukraine will also benefit from the eu's
mutual defense Clause under article 42.7
of the treaty on the European Union and
hopefully as a future NATO member it
will benefit from Article 5 of the
Washington treaty
however I'm afraid that years will pass
before Ukraine becomes a fully fledged
EU and NATO member hence we need to make
sure that the country obtains reliable
security guarantees until then
in addition Ukraine is counting on our
support
on the 10 point peace formula proposed
by president oladime merzelensky during
his address at the latest G20 Summit
this is another very important
initiative on which we need to focus our
attention in the coming months
our guest speakers today are the
initiators of the key of security format
Mr underscore Rasmussen welcome
and Mr Andrei German Mr Rasmussen was
the prime minister of Denmark and the
North Atlantic Treaty organizations
Secretary General and Mr Andre hermach
is head of the Office of the President
of Ukraine and the member of the
National Security and defense Council of
Ukraine
so it is great pleasure to welcome you
here and of course I look forward to
hearing the latest about the progress
you are making on the key of security
Compact and how European Parliament
Foreign Affairs committee security
defense subcommit in particular could
assist you in this
so thank you very much I stopped here my
starting monologue and I guess we
proceed now with our first guest speaker
I'd like to give the floor to Mr yeah
Mark please here the floor
first of all thank you for the this
opportunity and pleasure to speak here
in front of friends real friends
I'm glad to see those of you who have
visited us
and I would appreciate the others for
whom we should
for many coming to Ukraine is a huge
rethinking and attitude changing
experience
even though us who fought the they got
it all
here you understand
Russia did not defeat FASA
it just appropriated
from the very start of the all-out
Russian invasion the European Parliament
has been supporting Ukraine
in its struggle for freedom and
Independence
we really appreciate this support I
believe it's a very very important not
for Europe alone but for the whole world
what your moral compass is flawless
his recent year experience proves it is
the policy of value not pragmatic real
politic that they can change the world
for the better
but for these changes to take place we
have to do a lot more
the gremlin is planning new strategic
offensive and launching and the next
mobilization wave
Russian generals will send troops to
storm Ukrainian cities again
just as they are doing involvement
their fightings method is unchanged
since World War One
just drive Canon further into the Enemy
Lines in Russia human life has never
been valuable and soldiers are still
viewing as extendable
but one should understand clearly and
that distinctly
anti-war protest will not break out in
Russia
propaganda is still very effective there
besides living conditions in the Russian
Province are so Bleak that the ministry
of aggression and the Wagner's company
are not lacking recruits
they spit clear protests
Prospect of ending up to the black
plastic bag
the Kremlin craze to take revenge for
the defeats it's his suffered this year
it strives to achieve some victory in
any cost
pujin says is directly
if he succeeds propaganda will do the
rest and the Russian population will be
ready to suffer father
it will be ready to wage a long war of
attrition
their calculus is very simple
I can explain it's it's either the
Ukrainian proverb before the third one
gets further the teen one gets dead
it hasn't worked by now and it's won't
work later but they will try hard
the conclusion it's obvious
waiting is wrong
reacting is no longer enough
you need to be stepped ahead
needs to strengthen this sanctioned
pressure
the 3.5 drop in the Russia GDP it's not
enough to force its to end the war
and we would and we would highly
appreciate the European parliament's
assistance in adopting the 10 sanctions
package
sanctions against Russian propagandists
be expanded right away to
otherwise the TV producing cannot fodder
will defeat the fridge again
urgent and the veto is providing Ukraine
the entire range of the weapons
was its needs today but also we was it
will need tomorrow is many it may need
the European Union defends industrial
conflicts should be restricted restarted
sorry
and the Ukrainian Enterprises
should be allowed to join
let's put it clear time it's not in our
side
the longer we were last the more
resources it will be required the more
leaves it will be take
the more damage it will be caused to the
planet
we must inflict in cruising the quick
defeat on the Empire upset regime
Ukraine must fully restore its integrity
and sovereignty they think
internationally recognized borders
for us it's a precondition for just
peace
President Vladimir zilinski presented
the Ukrainian peace formula in November
g19 Summit and I spoke about it in
Dallas
so I wanted to go into detail just let
me emphasize the road maps basis and
priority is International Security
nuclear energy food Environmental
and Military security to applies to us
all Russian aggressions against Ukraine
started nine years ago
its full-scale face has been lingering
for the full nine nine months
this is the largest war in Europe in
nearly 80 years
in terms of forces involved but also in
the terms of the number of War crime
committed
and despite the fact that their victims
are ukrainians the crimes are aimed in
the wild of the humanity
Russia challenges the rules-based world
order
Russians believe that Ukraine their
fightings an entire West we have
thousands of testimonies of prisoners of
War confirming kids
and sees they believe it Russian
aggression against Ukraine is really
aggressions again the wild of the Europe
it is a war against the value that you
need us
it is pointless to seek a dialogue with
Moscow because it's not able to speak on
the equal footing
some governments still hope that betting
on Russia or standing natural will allow
them to realize their State's interest
they are wrong
Russia can't be grateful
helping him just gives you and slim
chances of being eaten last
but it's not for the sure Russian
aggression against Ukraine is evidence
that existing General Security
architecture which is built on the
United Nations chapter is enabled to
guarantee the security of states
the International Group which I have the
honor to co-chair with the Mr Rasmussen
his deep developed the draft of those
for Ukraine we call it the key security
compact
my co-chairman who I am blessed to
welcome here
we'll uh we'll talk about this
initiative in detail
I'll just underline Ukraine it's no way
consider the documents as subside for
the NATO membership
it's obvious when both today in and in
the foresible future with best security
guarantees are provided by Article 5 of
the Washington treaty
but we don't just hope to the get under
the collective security
umbrella still not a member State
Ukraine contributes much to Europe
Europe Atlantic security
it is high time to recognize Ukraine
it's illegible Russians have been
seeking to restore their empire
to recover Europe for web invasion of
Ukraine it's a milestone on the way to
Continental domination
we have paid the ultimate price to
disrupt the mouse's plot
we are extremely obliged to our European
and American Airlines and our partners
around the world to their constant and
valuable commitment to help Ukraine
our vast and terribly painful finding
experience and your AIDS combined health
insurance the DraStic increase in
Ukraine forces combat redness
said Ukraine is has already proven
capability with the alien standards we
are real for us on the battlefield and
in all aspects of our interactions
supporting Ukraine now it's an
investments in your current security
but granting Ukraine that a membership
is investments in your future security
we understand that reaching Universe
agreements it's time consuming
however time its dwelling resources for
all of us Ukraine welcomes Sweden and
Finland join NATO
and we very regret that this process is
being delayed
security issue should be undenatable
priority in today's world
meanwhile the Ramstein platform is
providing that NATO together this eats
outside the security partners
in a capable of acting fast
it's able to make weak life-changing
decisions
the aliens
as a multicello security mechanism of
transforming right before our eyes but
without Ukraine this transformation will
be not be completed
I think it's obvious to everyone present
here and I hope that you will be Ukraine
lobbyists and advocates in this respect
just as you have been until now and many
others
thank you very much for your listening
thank you very much Mr yeah give the
floor to understand
good afternoon and um thank you very
much
for the invitation to address you today
on the key security compact
um and I'm delighted that it's co-author
and the year mark uh who we have just
heard uh is also able to join us and
it's a pleasure to be back
uh in the European Parliament
the European Parliament has been a
steadfast supporter
of Ukraine over the past year
president Metzler was the first leader
of a European institution to visit
Ukraine after the invasion
and your committers have consistently uh
called for Europe to do more
both to help the Ukrainian people in
these dark moments and help their Armed
Forces win this war
I know that many of you in this room
were in Kiev last December
and that you discussed the key of
security compact while you were there
I was also pleased to see that at your
last plenary session the parliament
adopted a resolution
calling for the European Union too and I
quote support the principles of the key
of security compact
as an immediate solution for Ukraine
security
I've been informed that you have a new
plenary discussion on Thursday
uh before the the EU Ukraine Summit
um
I'm also informed that a resolution will
be tabled
um I hope
that in this final resolution after you
had a chance to look at it that there
will be formulations in this resolution
supporting the cave security compact
um your continued support in this house
and in your own member states will be
essential for adjust peace to Prevail in
Ukraine
our meeting today comes at a pivotal
moment
the situation in Ukraine remains
extremely precarious
Russia continues launching waves of
missile and drone attacks targeting
Ukrainian cities and Ukraine
infrastructure
the AIM December
to break down
their morale and to break the strong
links between the civilians and the
military
but despite these hardships the
Ukrainian population remained more
determined than ever to resist
within the European Union we also see a
moment of resolve and unity
Putin believed an energy crisis in
Europe would divide us
and lessen our supports for Ukraine
it did not
he also thought
his nuclear rhetoric and ever-changing
red lines would keep us from aiding
Ukraine
it did not
national leaders are
stepping up and giving Ukrainian forces
what they need on the battlefield
I've been
open in my criticisms when I felt some
European leaders were punching below
their weight
but I'm also the first to recognize when
leaders make the right course
this is what they did at the last
meeting in Ramstein and in deciding to
supply tanks
Germany sending main battle tanks
Ukraine
who would have thought
Denmark giving away all its Caesar
Tillery pierces to Ukraine
Spain talking about delivering between
22 50 leopards
these are truly historic decisions
finally
Europe is showing up on the scale needed
however
this is not a moment to Pat ourselves on
the back
this war is far from over
after having failed to divide and the
Intimidators Putin is hoping to outlast
us
Russell responded to Ramstein by
intensifying attacks on Ukrainian cities
so rather than anticipating a spring
offensive we should prepare for an
imminent one
Putin and his commanders know that the
battlefield window is closing
they will try to exert the maximum
destructive pressure now
they also think they can outproduce us
ironically
the best way to ensure this war ends
quickly
is for Ukraine's allies to prepare for a
long conflict
it is to deliver more and heavier
weapons to Ukraine
that is the best way to bring peace
we cannot allow
putting to win this war
if he gets success in Ukraine he will
continue
and a Putin
success in Ukraine would send an
extremely dangerous signal to autocrats
all over the world
if protein can get away
we're taking land from his neighbors
see yipping
and others might be tempted to try the
same
we must confidently reassess and ensure
the acquaintance have what they need
ahead of time
our approach so far has been to
incremental and ad hoc
this leaves us one step behind
and has allowed Putin to escalate
without consequences
you cannot win a war
by an incremental approach
you have to surprise and overwhelm
your enemy
and what we need is a long term
cohesive strategy
and
on this last point
I would focus
because that is ultimately what the key
of security compact seeks to do
Andrew yemack and I co-authored the
report at the request of president
zielinski
it is one of the key elements of
President zielinski's 10-point peace
plan
it outlines a robust set of guarantees
to ensure Ukraine's Independence and
territorial Integrity for the long term
so Russia can never invade again
and Ukraine can recover
and continue its path
of European integration
let me be clear
these guarantees are not a replacement
for Ukraine's ambition to join NATO
this is a decision for Ukrainian people
and by the way an ambition I support
but
a clear NATO membership will take time
the key of security compact is about
enhancing Ukraine security now and for
the future
it is based on the principle that
Ukraine's sovereignty depends first and
foremost on its ability to defend itself
the formula is
to make Ukraine capable to defend itself
by itself
for this Ukraine needs to maintain a
strong military
one capable of deterring and defeating
Russia on the battlefield
this will only be possible through a
sustained multi-decade commitment from
Ukraine's allies
under the care security compact
guarantee countries would commit to help
Ukraine in four major areas firstly
built a very strong Ukraine military
without any restrictions on size and
strengths
strong enough to withstand any future
Russian attack
secondly
enhance the sharing of intelligence
between Ukraine and its allies
thirdly
sustain intensive training missions
under both EU and NATO Flags and
fourthly
built a strong and modern defense
industry in Ukraine so Ukraine can
produce efficient weapons herself
this support
would come from a core group of
Ukraine's allies
a broader group
would then commit to imposing automatic
so-called Snapback sanctions on Russia
in case of further aggression
the key security compact does not
pretend to replace NATO's Article 5
Mutual defense clause
it proposes instead
reinforced self-defense to ensure peace
it also avoids the mistakes of the past
previous security guarantees for Ukraine
proved worthless
particularly the infamous Budapest
memorandum
this provided only negative security
guarantees
it prohibits it the signatories from
threatening or using military force or
economic coercion against Ukraine
but when Russia did exactly that
the consequences were minimal
the cave security compactors the
opposite it provides positive security
guarantees
giving practical material support to
enhance Ukraine's ability to defend
itself
Putin must understand
that the Democratic world's commitment
to Ukraine will not falter
that his war is futile
adopting a strong set of guarantee sense
exactly that message
we must build on the unity established
in Ramstein last month
we must think about what comes next
and I think the European Parliament
should be
the central voice in this
your continued support will be vital
to make the cube security compacted
reality
to provide a framework under which
Ukraine can recover rebuild and continue
the path to EU membership
so
that anyone who addresses this room in
years to come will also be addressing
Ukraine members
thank you very much and I'm ready to
take all your questions
foreign thank you very much Mr Rasmussen
let me give the floor now to be told
that shikovsky
I thank you Natalie Mr yerma Mr
Rasmussen I'm here and it's good to have
you with us I fully support your work
about the future position of Ukraine
these are the European Union and NATO I
understand that Kiev compact supposed to
lead to the full fresh membership of
Ukraine to Nato not to the provisional
substitutional solution
however Ukraine's situation is very
difficult today as you rightly mentioned
Russia is determined to contact the
world and escalate the world
so I wonder what from your experience of
your work on this compact we can or you
can use today
there are two definitions of Victory one
is to stop the world and to freeze the
conflict like in
2015. the second and I understand you
support the second is to win the war and
beat the Russians
these two definitions leads to lead to
the two different solutions to deliver a
weapon and help you cry
the River on the fancy weapon or deliver
offensive weapons so how they split
affect your work you you don't work in a
vacuum of course you have to
respect the opinion of other leading
countries
participating in this exercise
so what is the reaction of other leading
countries what is support for your
vision and what are the chances to
implement some of your objectives right
now as soon as possible thank you
thank you very much
I'm now going to give the floor to the
permanent reporter from
aphetamine in in Kiev and I'm very
grateful for this opportunity to get yet
another input for our deliberations and
our discussions how to make Europe and
Ukraine and us all of us more secure
after this uh Dreadful war and I'm happy
to say that this Parliament has uh been
always ahead of the wave of decisions so
meaning that I recall that in we had a
resolution already before the outbreak
of the war where we welcomed those
countries who at the time before the war
already delivered weapons and uh and so
far
um I think that was only one of the
points where we have argued that uh
support is necessary uh to Ukraine and
remains necessary and uh especially as
Mr Putin has not lost or dropped any of
his uh objectives and that is the end of
ukrainian's statehood of course and uh
in so far I um in principle would say uh
that I support the uh points that have
been made here uh what is necessary that
it has a strong military has to have one
and we need to enhance intelligence
sharing
um we need to continue intense training
and they have to rebuild their strong
defense industry they had an industry
already and there are not um
of course largely destroyed I wonder
um how we can get the discussion forward
amongst our governments I mean the the
it's as it is I just read well uh
Austria and Hungary just decided we will
not deliver weapons okay it's their
decision but that shows already some
hesitation or some breakup of uh of of
unity and which will of course Please Mr
Putin so I wonder uh where we as a well
as a parliament we can make our minds
heard but it is not at the end it's not
about us but it is about the governments
and and so far I I would wish that uh we
use and you use also your
um input and your your influence uh on
our respective governments that they
understand one thing there cannot be a
return to business as usual with this
Russia I think that is an
something that must really sick sink
into the minds of the politicians and
the decision makers in our capitals with
this Russia there is no return possible
to business as usual and uh that is the
real question how how to get unanimity
in this regard and in order to get the
Ukrainian message over I'm finishing and
that is where I address myself to Mr
yarmak and he knows what is coming now I
think there cannot be enough ukrainians
here in Brussels to make their point and
that is why I once again reiterate my
point to say I think it is not a good
decision to uh to block or to to reserve
the troubling of of members of the
parliament to uh to uh only very
restricted meetings but to allow anybody
who was wants to travel from the
parliament to conveys a message I think
that is important because otherwise I
have the feeling that the current ukas
in this regard is not quite
constitutional thank you
have you requested the floor so please
do keep your comments short essenti Tony
Lupita Madam thank you madam thank you
of course for joining us today it's a
great pleasure to see you again Mr
yermak after our meeting in Kiev in
December unfortunately the context of
our meeting did not change for better
almost a year since the start of Russian
aggression
we witnessed daily attacks on your
critical and civilian infrastructure
increasing number of casualties
of course thank you for presenting the
key of security compact as a way of
formalizing Coalition of supporters of
Ukraine through security guarantees
support of the EU has been unprecedented
with a positive decision on Leopard
tanks now the discussion is Shifting
towards fighting Jets this house
supported the delivering all the
necessary support on multiple occasions
one particular interesting aspect of
your proposal is a core group of allies
would make clear commitments to support
Ukraine's Armed Forces while a broader
group would provide non-military
guarantees built around sanctions
mechanisms I question could you provide
more information on practicalities of
this idea and the level of support it is
receiving
a second topic even though our issue
today is a key of security compact I
also would like to ask you Mr yermak
about domestic political situation and
your anti-corruption actions coming from
Croatia we had Direct experience with
post-war transition and so-called War
profiting President zielinski
highlighted domestic fight against
corruption and protection of State
assets as a national priority together
with defending the country as absolute
priority we saw some actions in that
regard could you share your assessment
on this thank you very much and good
luck with everything
thank you we knew
Petra Richard
let me to thank both Mr yarmaker and Mr
Erasmus and for their very great work I
mean they did in making this documents
congratulations it's a great uh you know
I mean concise and a clear guidelines
explaining very well to those who are
interested and follow this situation and
let me to quote
one line from your document given its
unique geopolitical position the most
effective security guarantees lie in
Ukraine's capacity to to defend itself I
think this is a very Central uh message
I mean we can get through it because you
know Ukraine is not a part of NATO
Ukraine has no collective security
guarantees all what we should think
about this in one way or another so
that's why
to my mind you rightly mentioned before
two things matter the most it's time and
team
time to provide as much as possible
because any delay
to supply Ukraine with needed weaponry
and ammunition
is more lives lost on the battlefield
and among civilians and team
building up Partnerships and mobilizing
all willing
civilized countries which are in
position to support Ukraine with what is
needed now but let me Mr Rasmussen to
ask you
since
guarantees are needed now not in future
not only through the defense capacity
being strengthened by all means but
maybe thinking about something else
extending our let's say political
thinking towards new Partnerships and my
question is whether is any possibility
to have for example NATO Europe
having more partnership agreements with
those countries which are willing and
able to cooperate and it's not just
about probably Ukraine but I'm looking
at Sweden for example as one example as
well if Turkey is to block accession of
this country absolutely illegitimately
to my mind but maybe we need some kind
of passarella
principle-based partnership with those
countries to support their security
guarantees thank you
thank you for the greens Reinhardt
thank you
thank you chair thanks also to our two
guests and presenters
the basic starting point as I understand
of the key of security compact lies in
the analysis that negative guarantees
have not worked and would not work in
the future
and I agree with that assessment
for the time being of course
we have to concentrate everything we do
on
contributing as best we can and with
whatever is needed
to help Ukraine winning on the ground
against the uh expected new Russian
offensives and in order to uh liberate
more of the occupied territory that is
still under the control of Russian Armed
Forces
as regards the positive guarantees that
you foresee in your document which we
welcome
I think there are two sticking points
that I find not clearly explained
one point
is this
in NATO and within the EU
we're trying to develop a system of
collective security
whereas this thinking in the document
basically focuses on a coalition of the
Willing of individual countries
how do you reconcile those two different
logics
and the second point is
and you will not be surprised
both President Biden the chancellor of
Germany and other leaders have argued
time and time again that they would not
allow
NATO or NATO member states
to become warring parties in this war
how do you
deal with that concern
in the context of the compact thank you
thank you very much Madam chair
and thank you I'm here
uh thank you for your speeches at the
beginning
well uh Secretary General thank you for
being back in European Parliament after
some break uh is great possibility for
us I've got a it's a matter of very
simple question
I think on behalf of our citizens
ordinary citizens because we can say
that our European Union in helping
Ukraine is a great success
on the other hand
I hear more and more
question
why does NATO but also individual
members States members delay with its
military support to Ukraine
how to explain it to ordinary citizens
we can understand as politicians and for
many reasons of course it is it is
possible to understand
but
it will be more and more important
questions
because we know what is going on in
Ukraine
and for our citizens is not easy to
understand
thank you very much
apologize for giving the wrong group it
was EPP
we'll presume now
yeah
thank you
well I am very concerned when I listen
into the discussions
today
we're on a war slide a slider War
and the obvious end is a big bump at the
end
we're looking at
a total war through to destruction
and it seems that no one is considering
anything else I what about negotiations
I haven't heard anything about that we
need to resume negotiations if we're to
stop this loss of human life
it seems to me that there's too much
love of War here and certainly German
history teaches us that that doesn't end
well
so I think that we should at least
discuss the option of negotiating
before proceeding because the way that
we're proceeding when we're not even at
one year of this war but we're looking
at 5
000 Steam
steel helmets originally delivered by
Germany and now we're looking at the
deliveries of leopard tanks
I've also heard about sharing military
intelligence
that seems to me to be a highly
dangerous idea because then we would be
actually Crossing an international
legal Red Line
if we are involved in providing
information that would damage or an
adversary then we are a party to war so
we I think we need to turn away from
this path and I would encourage my
colleagues to reconsider the idea of
diplomatic Solutions and negotiations
perhaps you could add that to your
vocabulary once more secondly I'd like
to know whether NATO which intends to
adopt this softer solution
are you still intending to avoid further
spillages of blood
if I think about Angela merkel's policy
on refugees there seems to have been a
real shift here then there's the
question of corruption europol is saying
that we're talking about a small
Weaponry through to
rocket launchers which are being sold on
the black market do we have any kind of
handle on what is happening to the
Weaponry that we are delivering
and then tying in with that corruption
question I'm wondering about what
happens with all of the money that we
are sending to Ukraine we're shoveling
it across to Ukraine is it just
disappearing into individuals Pockets
I'm not saying this just as a rhetorical
question because even president
zielinski has had to admit that there is
a real problem with widespread
corruption and I think we need to pay
more attention to that so those were two
questions essentially and I'd really
like to hear your answers
thank you let's go around with a second
set of questions let me just remind you
that defending a well protecting a
country which has been attacked does not
qualify as an act of War
providing supplies does not constitute
an act of War it is only Russian
propaganda that would make that claim
Andreas kobelius for the Epp
thanks very much to both speakers really
great job
and definitely you know
uh
Ukraine is is doing you know incredible
job in defending not only itself but
also all of us
and if to go back into the history it's
obvious that NATO or back in 1949 was
created to deter and to defend you know
Europe against the
authoritarian Russia or Soviet Union
expansion and Invasion and now Ukraine
is doing that job
NATO was created for collective security
Ukraine is doing it alone with its
self-defense capabilities which yoga
security compact you know are looking
how to increase but it looks like you
know that those were good ideas which
you put into security compact
uh you know
designed because still we are not able
to speak about real membership of
Ukraine in NATO
which from my point of view would be big
benefit also for NATO and folcrain
itself and I understand that last year
it was looking like you know
you know a little bit not believable
that we can start to speak about Ukraine
membership in NATO
I think that this year could be a
different
because there are only two reasons from
my point of view and you know Mr
Rasmussen perhaps knows much more about
NATO but at least from my point of view
there are two reasons why we are
hesitating you know when we are talking
about Ukrainian membership in need one
is that you know still some people are
afraid to provoke Putin reaction
I can argue that exactly opposite
Ukrainian membership in NATO with
strengths and possibility of Russia to
become a democracy because that's what
you know kill you know the dream to
restore Empire among Russian people
second of course the reason is that you
know maybe member states do not want
immediately to jump into the war but
that is the question of how to invite
Ukraine into to become a member of NATO
it's not to know that Ukraine should
become member of NATO immediately today
but that is what is a real solution so
my question is are we going to real
solutions at some time
foreign
mixer please thank you very much to both
of the speakers we have been saying uh
time and again that uh we will support
Ukraine for as long as it takes and
obviously there's a logical connection
uh the the how long it will take will
directly depend on how how much and how
quick will it quickly we give uh now
until a year ago I think most of us
worked on the assumption that Russia was
is essentially deterrable that it was a
rational player uh now the the the
aggression launched by Putin and the way
he has been conducting the aggression I
think seemed to suggest that he is not
entirely rational or at least that he is
ready to take much much more pain and
and and far bigger losses than we
previously thought in order to to
achieve his Imperial Ambitions and that
that means that deterring Russia will
will uh incur much higher price then
perhaps we thought previously before
this this aggression uh you suggested in
the compact that that we would need to
help Ukraine build up defenses that
would be capable of deterring uh Russia
and uh so far we have been dragging our
feet about delivering a few dozens of
battle tanks and and and and and a few
fighter planes so would you uh perhaps
like to like to suggest as to what and
in what quantities we need to give uh to
Ukraine in order for it to be able to
actually deter
putting putting structure and and I
personally tend to agree with Andrew
scobili's in that perhaps
helping Ukraine to get into a NATO and
under the collective security umbrella
would be uh well
an intellectually more compelling uh way
of of providing long-term security to to
the country and and also to other
countries because building up Ukraine's
defenses would not necessarily help to
provide security for countries like
Moldova and others the caucus countries
were also living under the threat of an
expansion institution imperialist Russia
Europe
is
I've listened with a deep concern when
you mentioned that Ukraine needs to win
the war
do you really think that Ukraine can
beat a power the size of Russia a
nuclear power I'm very concerned about
this do you really think they can take
Crimea back through the
oh well can they go via the straights or
they have to have a Normandy style
Invasion we need to be realistic
secondly when you say that uh Ukraine
has to focus on the self-defense via as
a high production of weapons in order to
produce weapons there has to be buyers
because you can't maintain a defense
industry a defense industry just on
domestic purchasing so
as you said you want to see the export
of these weapons because that's needed
for economic uh justification this is a
war that Ukraine cannot win and Russia
cannot lose
what we need to do is uh to arm Ukraine
so that negotiation uh is a real
negotiation with Russia in a position of
weakness however to see a fully full
Ukraine
um Victory I think that's uh
ridiculous I'm concerned because that
means we would have to
um declare war on Russia with the blood
of the ukrainians and I think this is a
morally indefensible if we think that
the the victory of Ukraine will be as a
result of the implosion of Russia
creating Afghanistan in in Europe and so
that we can now see the
uh
this situation it would be hundreds of
thousands of uh lives lost if they don't
win the war then what will we have a
permanent War for how long and in what
Manner would it be conducted I think we
are looking at a position which means
that we are
um up against Russia via the blood of
the ukrainians
uh conclude can we be uh can we
beat a nuclear power using a country
which has a low much lower population
and and lower capacity and I think
um extremely concerned by this uh
initial approach uh to win this war
which is unwinnable
once again for the EPP uh rainbow
I'll think about them president
Secretary General
I will repeat what I said by few months
what time we hesitate
to supply Ukraine
with the nursery military weapons
military equipments
being able to attack
the logistic basis the aviation basis
and the Russian ships from the Black Sea
all situated on the on the Russian
territory Ukraine don't have any chance
in fact the Russians are destroying
daily the Ukrainian infrastructure and
in another hand the ukrainians are not
supplied with the necessary weapons to
attack the logistic basis which are on
the Russian territory Aviation bases
which are on the Russian territories and
the ships which are on the Black Sea
in fact
we have to be clear that without of such
measures with such deliveries
Ukraine don't have any chance
this is
my message we have to be more courageous
because on the end of the day the
Russians are attacking Ukraine from the
Russian territory not from the Ukrainian
territory
merci
thank you for the yesterday
thank you Mr Elizabeth give me the flow
I don't know if Mr yermak is still
online can he answer a question yes
question is for you according the German
newspaper develop Bulgaria provided a
third of ukrainian's arms needed in uh
during the last year and the Ukrainian
government confirmed this news the
bulgarians learned about this great role
of our country with big emotions and
political newspaper based in Brazil Eva
Road Bulgaria secretly saved Ukraine so
can you provide more information Mr
airmock which part of the sent weapons
was extremely important and helped to
save to crania and the second question
is to Mr Rasmussen
um Mr Ermac just said time is not on our
side
so how far and quick do we expect Nate
to be even more engaged in the war in
Ukraine if sending of the tanks do not
turn the tide of the war and as well the
eventual sending of military plans if so
is it necessary will be necessary to
according to your opinion to send
military troops from NATO countries and
for from where to expect such assistance
first Poland Romania and Bulgaria could
be among the first ones and please Mr
Hamas Rasmussen b as Frank as possible
and is Europe entering in a war with
Russia or we already at War
it was said by the foreign minister of
Germany and do we have a strategy as a
European Union as NATO members any
strategy how to stop this war thank you
let's see thank you for every new Europe
and drag us to the ratchet please
thank you chair and the most welcome to
to both distinguished guests and
speakers
one question is linked to a discussion
on Victory we've heard several
colleagues exposing different versions
of what victory looks like and
my question is whether in your
discussions uh the initiators of the
compact group whether there is already a
clear understanding of what victory
looks like and how do you think we can
get to a broader shared understanding of
what this Victory looks like because
it's quite essential
to actually what would need to do in the
actions we need to take to get there
and this leads me to the second question
you said uh Secretary General yourself
that we have to surprise and overwhelm
if we want to this your exact words to
surprise and overwhelm Russia and I
fully agree but do you think that what
we are currently doing and supplying
Ukraine with is capable to surprise and
overwhelm Russia or rather to just get
by
thank you
finally for the greensky
um the second round of the greens
um uh very briefly I think this
discussion is very useful and I think
the authors of of the paper but what I'm
concerned about is that in our
discussion the immediate needs of
ukrainians and the vision of what and
how we want to secure uh Ukrainian
security and Ukrainian future are mixed
together and the way I understand your
proposal uh your proposal is a vision of
what will come
um following the War uh and I think we
all agree that following the war our
relationship and the relationship that
we understand uh will be for Ukraine
vis-a-vis Russia will be a relationship
of containment and deterrence
and if uh we are we agree that we can
only live with the Russia under Putin uh
by means of containment and deterrence
then we must make sure that Ukraine can
deter
and I understand this paper as a road
map uh towards a Ukraine that can deter
Russia from the future from that
perspective uh the uh comments that I
heard from Mr zimiak are irrelevant
because diplomacy cannot deter Russia as
we know it and we all agree that
diplomatic instruments are important but
they are not part of the tools tool
basket that you're offering because they
did not deter Russia so far and they
will not deter Russia in the future
under Putin so uh from that perspective
I uh would like to see it and I would
like to ask you uh the question of the
time access that you are proposing what
elements because some elements that your
proposal are already in work for example
our help in terms of military equipment
training Etc what elements do you think
can be implemented already now
and what elements should be implemented
following the victory of Ukraine of a
Russian aggressor in whatever form we
understand this victory of following
this war so what is I I see the vision
but I don't see the roadmap what would
be the road map that you propose thank
you very much
well after that long list of questions
I'd like to give the flow back to our
guest to respond uh beginning with Mr
yermak if you're still with us
um first of all thank you very much for
everybody
if I can I will answer because a lot of
questions I will answer in Ukrainian you
have the translation
um
first of all I would like to thank you
all
especially those who said
that at the background on the
conversations
uh shall we should we give or should not
we give assistance we have to forget
about it we have to be united we have to
help Ukraine to get a victory in this
War I am very thankful for you these
words are especially important for us
nowadays secondly I would like to very
clearly yet again and I have talked
about it many many times also during our
meetings where our colleagues from the
European Parliament were in cave we do
not have
any scenario
how the victory will look like that will
not include 100 recovery of territorial
sovereignty of Ukraine within the
international recognizable borders
territorial Integrity hundred percent
all other proposals with regard to the
negotiation
until last Russian soldier leaves our
country our Russian propaganda Natalie
thank you very much that you openly
mentioned that also I would like to say
that under the president zielinski and I
think
I'm don't think I am sure I am convinced
because this is the position of the
Europe Ukrainian people we won't have
any Minsk formant any other new Norman
deformats we won't have it these you can
and have to understand very well those
with skepticism they say is it possible
to win over Russia is it possible to be
victorious over the nuclear State Etc
what I would like to say is the
following already for 11 months we do
not talk we demonstrate you with facts
that we did not only deter and stop this
aggression we starting to liberate step
by step all our territories and we will
liberate them clearly and fast
if and when we have the necessary weapon
I would like you to understand
and unfortunately
those
who still did not have an opportunity to
come to us I invite you
please understand your position will
change 100 percent
for example the Prime Minister minister
of Denmark
that was yesterday
was President visited mikolai in Odessa
frankly spoke about it
even
though she was already during this war
in cave but what she saw in mikolai in
Odessa region uh just surprised her a
lot
I would like to say that we deal with
the modern Fascism and I am not mistaken
fascism that's what I meant
if someone does not believe me please
look again through the history of the
World War II look through the history of
concentration camps because they do
exist nowadays on the occupied
territories on the territory of the
Russian Federation and again I call upon
all of you who is in doubt please come
to Ukraine we will provide you with a
secure and safe stay but you will be
able to see everything with your own
eyes regarding NATO during my statement
I said that today that's the most secure
a lie
NATO is and I would like to mention
somebody mentioned that when NATO was
created in 1949
NATO already at that time as
organization
was mentioning the huge threat from the
site on the Soviet Union later on it
became threat from Russia and I would
like to remind you that for a long
period of time during last dozens of
years we had this axioma
that
we cannot uh have like equivalence on
the same level Russia and NATO are light
countries and many of
uh people uh where
um stressed
they
were really thinking that this is like
the second biggest army in the world
it's impossible to fight against them
and the policy was based upon that
please do not mistake they do not repeat
this mistake we Ukrainian we showed you
that we fight for our
um values
today we are the best uh Matchmaker for
NATO we have shown where NATO is and
where Russia is Russia understands very
well they cannot dictate any conditions
to any of the NATO countries please
let's together keep that safe
because today thousands of thousand
Ukrainian soldiers as Citizens paid for
it Ukrainian Children's Life lost
because of it and I am convinced that
the membership of Ukraine in NATO will
only strengthen this Alliance we cannot
lose the country that works today and
fights today the
people in the entire world will be
convinced that NATO is the strongest
organization in the world Natalia thank
you very much that you reminded me on
the one of the priorities of President
zielinski
and I want to mention that he was very
successful businessman and the only goal
that he
went to be a president it's to change
this country and please look
at what Ukraine uh has done
under his presidency Canada see to the
European Union
how much he did and we're talking about
the war time
we're talking here about construction of
the
anti-corruption system and what I like
to mention that everything would it's
told about the level of corruption in
Ukraine as I think overblown because if
we talk about the very corrupted country
as a Russian propaganda States a lot
about it
such a corrupted country would not be
able to fight and stand strong for
almost 12 months that's why despite this
skepticism even some political parties
that now call themselves European
parties the president the landscape
had the initiative to fight against
oligarchs and today the realization of
this law is one of the point that the
European commission told us to do and we
will realize it believe us and that
currently you see that
anti-corruption cases
we have in our courts all this it's only
in support that even during this war our
community our people are united around
our president around our Victory we are
clearing them ourselves as a society but
please do not overblow the size of
volume it's only in favor for the
Russian propaganda because they do want
this to be a case but it's not the truth
everything what is happening today and I
can tell you even what kind of
Institutions are those we have very
strong anti-corruptional institution in
Ukraine I don't think many countries
have such institutions in the world
talking about the country's other
countries I there are many countries
but I'm using this opportunity would
like to say that we are thankful to all
of you we won't forget you never
we will remember all our friends our
partners that during those practically
12 months support us help us there are
many countries I thank all of you I
thank you governments I thank you
leadership and first of all your people
your societies because we all know how
simple people support ukrainians in many
European countries in majority of the
European countries because they already
understand that Ukraine is a part of the
European family and believe me that we
work 24 7 to this goal so it will become
a reality as soon as possible we will
have and one day the summit European
Union Ukraine we are well prepared for
it we expecting our partners and friends
to come to us we expect to have good
decision to be adopted during this
Summit
and
as a conclusion I would like to say
that during this 12 months
historical things happened and one of
those events it's
unconditional Unity of the democratic
world around Ukraine
it is really truth but also I would like
to say
that we are united around our values
unfortunately we're starting forgetting
about them
but
that the evil and fascism will not win
we need to keep this Unity because this
is a forepost that the Free World will
win and Ukraine is now at the Forefront
of this fight please do not forget about
it please I would like to also thank to
all of those who mentioned that every
day unfortunately we are losing our
people today
uh we live in the conditions like for
example today three times
for a couple of uh hours we had Air Raid
Sirens wailing people living in Ukraine
currently they do not know what today
will bring them they do not have
electricity they do not have water but
believe me
I am Frank with you 100 percent
I'm telling you ukrainians will keep on
this road we will win
and yet again I would like to thank all
those who believe like we believe in our
common Victory and convince those who
are still skeptical about it believe me
you are wrong
Russia will not win in this war Ukraine
will be victorious thank you very much
glory to Ukraine
thank you Mr yamak for those very clear
messages and for obviously the the
Gratitude and the support that you have
from us and uh vasta public support you
have from across Europe you need to
continue fighting against the worst
imperialism of modern times another to
the floor to uh Andes Rasmussen to
answer the different questions which is
asked
Messi Madam president
um and thank you very much for your very
interesting very relevant questions it's
actually a great pleasure to be back and
in the audience also see some well-known
faces where whom I have served in
different capacities over the years I
will do my best to quickly answer all
your your questions Mr
butchowski asked me how does Victory
look like and others have actually
touched upon the same issue
it's very easy Victory is to kick all
Russian troops out of Ukraine
that's how it looked like because I can
assure you as long as you have Russian
troops
on Ukrainian soil there'll be a conflict
and we need peace to start rebuilding
and reconstruction of Ukraine and that's
why
the only off-ramp for Putin is out of
Ukraine it's very simple
and to that end we need to deliver to
the ukrainians everything they need to
achieve that goal
um
you also asked me what has been the
reaction to the key of security compact
I traveled to Washington twice
before and after the midterm elections I
spoke with representatives of the
administration as well as members of
both parties in Congress I left
uh Washington a bit more optimistic than
I arrived
um the administration is in principle in
principle
uh in favor of the waters in the Q
security compact
and both political parties are very
supportive apart from
a small minority on the Democratic left
and a small majority on the Republican
right but apart from that there is a
strong bipartisan support for the
principles in the cape security compact
so I left Worthington
um
uh encouraged but
still we haven't seen real progress and
this is the reason why my plea is
for the European Parliament to issue a
new strong Declaration of support for
the keep security compact
and and I think you have a chance
already on on Thursday and
it leads me to an answer to Mr Gala who
asked me how to speak with governments
on this I agree that's important how can
we convince governments
um that keeps security compact is an
important element on the way forward
I can tell you what I have tried to to
to argue firstly
the key security compact is necessary
to issue the necessary security
guarantees for Ukraine so that
investors
uh dare to actually put their money in
the Reconstruction rebuilding Ukraine
you need a long-term security guarantee
to create an attractive investment
environment secondly
we have a strong interest in building a
strong and stable Eastern European
partner as you like Ukraine as a pollock
against a still more aggressive Russia
and by that we can create more
um stability and long-term peace on the
European continent
which
eventually will also leave more room
maneuver to address the real long-term
Global challenge China and the
indo-pacific
in addition to that I have argued I
think the key security compact it can
also build the bridge within NATO to
avoid splits at the upcoming Summit in
real news because no doubt there'll be a
discussion on Ukrainian membership of
NATO
you have allies that are strong in favor
you have Allied skeptical and you have
allies that are 100 against for the time
being at least
but I think to avoid that split we have
the key security compact which de facto
is a codification of what we're already
doing
but with a more long-term strategic
perspective
that's the way I've tried to convince
governments that it is in our
self-interest to sign the key of
security compact
Mr Petula asked me about sanctions how
will that work well it would be far too
much to go into all the details but I
can tell you that uh Japan Australia
South Korea are among countries that
have showed strong interest
uh in in joining a sanctions regime
um and I think it would be
dangerous to abolish sanctions uh too
early
uh
but once we think that conditions have
been fulfilled
for lifting or modifying some sanctions
then we have to monitor the situation
and if Russia repeats its attack on
Peaceful neighbors then they will
automatically be reintroduced so that's
actually the essence of this
um Mr burikova asked me
if NATO is part of the war
no NATO is not part of the war
will we consider individual NATO allies
as part of the war
yes in a way yes
we shouldn't hide that
because according to article 51 in the
U.N Charter
every country that is attacked has the
right to defend itself of course but it
also has the right to request assistance
from allies to help it counter that
attack and that's exactly what the
Ukrainian government has done
so we shouldn't be surprised that we
more or less are part of this war to
defend Ukraine and it is in full
accordance with international law
Mr botek
I don't understand why
we have delayed the delivery of weapons
the fact is that those delays are
exploited by Putin while we're debating
And discussing his accelerating
without any consequences he started
attacking a civilian infrastructure in
Ukraine back in October and we didn't do
anything
so
um
I like you I don't understand it but I
appreciate that finally the right
decision was taken in Ramstein and a
couple days later by the Durham
government
Mr
um
simnuk
acute
we need negotiations to end the war
well
maybe that depends
but I don't think
it will be negotiations
around the table that will determine the
outcome of this war it will be the
position on the battlefield
so we have to deliver all the assistance
that the ukrainians need to strengthen
their hands
when they feel that the time is ripe for
negotiations it's not for us
to push the acquaintance to engage in
premature peace negotiations
um
there is one easy way to stop this war
Russia should stop
attacking Ukraine
it's very easy
if Russia stops the war stops fighting
there will be no war
if the ukrainians stop fighting there'll
be no Ukraine
it is as easy as that
um and that's of course why
it's a key component of President
zelinski's t-point peace plan 10 point
peace plan that
the Russian troops should leave Ukraine
before you can even start negotiations
um
Mr kobilius
asked me about NATO membership uh
for Ukraine
why hasn't it happened already are we
afraid of provoking coating We could
decide now
without it entering into Force
immediately but maybe later but actually
we have used that formula back in 2008
in Bucharest we decided that Ukraine
will become member of NATO
Without End date but it will happen one
day in the future and that decision
still stands
um
but of course
it is a bit complicated if if we were
imagining uh giving Ukraine membership
of NATO now they would be covered by
article 5. which means
that the U.S and other big allies would
be obliged to help Ukraine against
Russian attacks that would really engage
NATO directly in a war with Russia and
this is the reason why
even I
who is strong in favor
of Ukrainian membership of NATO think
that it would be better
to introduce the key security compact
and really pledge
to give Ukraine
firm security guarantees as a first step
which could pave the way
for a future membership of NATO
because the key of security compact
would really be a bulwark against future
Russian attacks
because you can be sure
Russia
as we know Russia Today at least will
continue its aggressive behavior so we
we need that bulwark and that's why we
need security guarantees anyway
and on top of that down the road uh
Ukraine can become a member of NATO
Mr mixer asked me what would it take
to deter Russia
that's also very easy
every all the weapons
that Ukraine needs
um
everything
and that's why
uh I think it has been a weakness
through this war that
leaders within NATO
and other allies and partners have been
too eager
to tell the world and tell Putin what
they exclude to do
so by that they have given Putin too
much room of maneuver in my opinion
I I wouldn't exclude anything in advance
there might be things we we would never
do but why teleported he the most
efficient deterrence is to keep your
adversary
um uncertain of how you would react when
you will react
even truth on the ground and even
nuclear weapons sorry to interrupt
the Ukraine has signed the
non-proliferation treaty actually this
whole
um
story started back in 1994.
after the collapse of Soviet Union a lot
a lot of nuclear weapons were left back
in Ukraine but in 1994
Ukraine signed the non-proliferation
treaty
and gave up the nuclear weapons actually
handed them over to Russia
in exchange Russia signed the Budapest
memorandum
where they pledged not to attack
Ukraine we all know what happened do you
think that would have happened if
Ukraine had still the nuclear weapons no
Ukraine doesn't have a nuclear weapon
and Ukraine doesn't want the nuclear
weapons so we can include exclude uh
that option I take that for forgiven but
apart from that I don't think we should
exclude anything
um okay but because let's realize
appeasement with dictators does not lead
to peace on the contrary it leads to war
and conflict because the dictator's
appetite is endless
now Mr Hunt
find it uh
ridiculous to think that the ukrainians
can actually win the war
because
the ukrainians are up against a nuclear
power
again I would say
never ever
give in to nuclear blackmail
those who give in to nuclear blackmail
are condemned to live in slavery under
the stick and pleasure of the nuclear
master
so we should never ever accept that kind
of blackmail
um I would
I wouldn't
I wouldn't like to live in a world
ruled by the tyrants
who possess nuclear weapons just because
they have nuclear weapons so we have to
uh
the
so we have to um to abide by their
dictates never ever that's why I I
always say
peace is precious but freedom is
priceless
we should always remember that and you
caution against a permanent War I can
assure you if we give in to Putin
we will have a permanent war in Europe
because Putin will not stop if he gets
success in Ukraine he will continue
first Moldova then Georgia and
eventually the Baltic states in
particular Lithuania because he wants to
create a Transit a Russian transit to
kaliningrad through Lithuania
that's how I see it
no
we don't Supply Ukraine with the
necessary weapons
um and you're right Russia is attacking
uh Ukraine from Russian territory so
obviously we should provide uh the
acquaintance with long-range missiles
obviously I I fully agree
um
um yeah I think Madam young I have
already answered your your questions
about NATO engagement NATO as such is
not engaged but NATO allies are of
course uh you and I don't think you will
see NATO troops uh deployed on on
Ukrainian uh on Ukrainian soil and
anyway it is a cotton in accordance with
international law that individual NATO
members uh help Ukraine so it's possible
it's possible
you think it's possible
um
out of time
um so thank you
yeah
um no I don't to be brief no I don't
think you'll see that
um
Mr uh lagudinski
yes you you requested a roadmap I think
we are already doing sharing of
intelligence we are already doing
training not on Ukrainian soil but in
NATO member states so that's already
done
um I think for later we as I mean to to
help Ukraine build a strong defense
industry that will take place at a later
stage
um
you may the first point to build a
strong military
that's in a way part of our weapon
deliveries now so you might argue that's
already happening so towards
strong degree
the cave security compact is codifying
what is already going on
um and
let me stress I think it's important to
sign the key security compact now and
not make it dependent on and enter the
conflict because that will de facto give
Putin yet another argument to continue
the conflict to avoid
the entering into force of the key
security compact that's why we should
sign it sooner rather than later
so let me just finish this
by saying that
now
we will have to to act
while we are debating And discussing
life
is lost in Ukraine and I think we have a
responsibility to put a quick end to
this war
and
the more weapons the heavier weapons the
faster they're delivered
the faster we can bring this war to an
end thank you
thank you very much Mr Rasmussen thank
you very much Mr Irma in Ukraine in Kiev
and of course Ukraine must win and
restore
uh full control over a territory
and of course Europe has to do
everything to support Ukrainian people
and of course first of all
security and full security for Ukraine
is absolute must and that's why also
Kiev security compact to be to be
implemented is is very
urgent issue but of course there are
also lots of many other issues like
creating International Tribunal
uh like uh using and find a way how to
use Russian assets to finance the
rebuilding of Ukraine and a lot of other
important issues so that I'm really glad
that the European Parliament has been a
very clear and vocal in all these issues
and of course European Parliament will
continue to support
Ukraine and Ukrainian people once again
thank you and
we have to stick together and and keep
supporting Ukrainian people till then
very positive
end of this tragic
aggression thank you